uh it's so nice to have you here and you
really do look stunning you don't get to
dress like this on the walking dead not
that much no
there's not a lot of like cocktail
parties no it's the zombies
how they do flashbacks and we go and see
like maggie at her prom or something
like this yeah maggie in some
spectacular location eating caviar yes
exactly i'm curious because the show i'm
a big fan of the show i've watched every
single one i'm all caught up and uh very
excited that the show's coming back but
i'm just
i'm curious about something which is at
the beginning of the show the zombies
were this uh presence they'd show up and
it'd be like this really scary thing
now it almost feels like they're around
all the time and you guys have become
used to them you know how to deal with
them so they're in the background and
you're almost bored by the by the
walkers isn't that true a little bit
yeah they're kind of part of the family
and they're it's really funny because
you get these very domestic scenes and
then in the background it's just this
kind of like drooping ghoulish
disgusting zombies trying to still claw
into our yeah live you'll just be like
making pancakes and one will go by in
the background exactly holding out how's
it going yeah
[Laughter]
while you're over there could you grab
the butter
yeah we have this still of you guys and
they're just they're all in the
background they're like oh what a nice
day yeah
my butter lettuce is turning out great
yeah yeah
hiya walkers where do they get you guys
shoot in atlanta and where do you get
all the zombies have you used pretty
much every
extra in the atlanta area has everyone
in atlanta been a walker at this point
yeah we're moving to charleston now to
find some new ones um no we have uh we
have we have used a lot of people we
have it's really funny that scene
because it's not in this season but last
season
the one time we had a standout zombie
that wasn't stella was stephen and i had
this scene at the end and glenn comes to
apologize to maggie and um it's a very
tearful scene and he apologizes and she
decides and there's like you know the
single tier and then i turn
and in the background behind this fence
is the zombie going
and like doing this whole thing and i
was like oh is that a suggestion or
um why was this why was the actor doing
that he i think he was just getting
really into the moment
of the scene maybe he felt like zombies
need romance too that's nice
it's just a perv zombie in the back
i think they think they're not going to
get noticed because there's so many and
you have these hordes and maybe he just
thought let's just sneak this one in i
would think it'd be nice
if you're on the show the walking dead
you could probably just meet people and
say hey you want to be a walker
because they don't even have to probably
be you know if they're way in the
background they're one of 10 000
walkers they don't even have to be a
trained actor right no they don't have a
friend
you could have a friend as long as your
friend had the right stats like i
actually went to i was in a hotel and it
was very funny and i hope they didn't
take it the wrong way but i went up to
this family and they were very sweet and
they recognized me from the show and
they were like oh my god you know we
love your show and stuff and i said
that's nice we're chatting and thinking
god there's a lot of flanky people this
is kind of crazy
like like tall skinny tall and skinny
stuff you know um
and they took um
and they took it pretty well because i
suggested they should be on the show and
they came on this because is that sort
of a requirement of a zombie is that
they need to be like yeah you emailed
extra's casting remember
didn't you email excess costing i would
love to be a zombie i would love to i
would love to be on the walking dead
yeah and i would have like one scene
and i want to be noticeable as conan
o'brien yeah yeah everything else is
rotted but the dessert hair candy what's
that and you could be chasing i'll be
chasing andy and amy's trying to get
away
shoelaces came undone and you kind of
like just at the last moment thought you
were going to get away and then you
tripped and then and then what happened
yeah
and then you made out like yeah
yes yeah finally our make out scene yeah
wait only one thing can stop that zombie
[Music]
there's a lot of tongues